yeah you guys did our journey across
japan yeah yeah it's been going where we
got like a
top 15 itunes hit i can't [ __ ]
believe that
i don't know how i spend so much of my
time like just off camera you know
making my own music and putting my hand
soul into it and yeah
the most successful piece of music i've
ever written
i wrote in seven hours in a couple years
often a cruel
i know you know i'll take the award it's
all right yeah so like for those who
aren't in the know what's the story
behind that
we had a challenge we had to do like a
rap song so on jenny across japan this
travel series
we get a challenge every day and the
challenge was to produce a rap song in a
day
and uh we found ourselves a volcano and
that became we had to rap about our day
right yeah
and we were on the top of japan's
biggest volcano mount assay
and that became it and natsuki said
something like whoa too much volcano
yeah it is isn't it that's the wrap yeah
say that over and over again say that
i very cleverly didn't put myself in the
wrap before the video
so that's good took the uh
took the credit but yeah yeah it turned
out really well yeah and then just shout
i put it on itunes right it costs like
to put a song on itunes yeah and it
takes like a few weeks and it's very
simple
but after i did that i shouted out and
it started to go up someone sent me a
link saying
are you in the top 25 alternative songs
on itunes i was like
i was kind of like like for that week
right so it's like oh okay you know
like it's probably because of the the
initial push yeah yeah yeah yeah
but but then it just it just kept going
it's just yeah
yeah once i shouted out that were on
itunes it created this sort of
self-propelling
sort of cycle people funded it more
bought it more it went up and up until
it got to
i think number 14 on the the itunes
singles chart worldwide
these poor people who bought this it's
terrible
it is worryingly catchy it's quite
addictive yeah the song hook
with that skin there's too much volume
yeah the asr too much volcano it works
it works but uh yeah so i don't know how
much it's sold
i don't know either i'm still waiting
for my royalties to be honest
well yeah so i wasn't going to split
with that skin jerry because i thought
it'd be like make a hundred
dollars yeah i'll use that to buy a
coffee or a new hat
yeah ten hats that's a thousand that's a
thousand hats
the drip game but because probably
around ten thousand people bought it
that's a bit more money and it makes
sense to split that with yeah with the
onaski i think you should pocket it
only sold a hundred copies you're
mirroring the music industry where the
the guy behind yeah the producer takes
all the money
but uh yeah i don't unfortunately it
takes about three months for itunes to
tell you how well it's done
so one day in september i'll be like
sitting in the room depressed and then
i'll get
a little letter from itunes but by the
way you've got platinum
wow platinum don't know what that is so
we'll see but yeah
on linkedin top 14
i think i think platinum means a million
yeah
do we have permission to play a short
clip on the podcast copyright strike
time
yeah exactly it's the only like the only
song that's not copyright
yeah easy to your advantage put it
everywhere yeah let's just get those
sails off
now we're chilling at the peak of the
volcano it looks kind of bleak but it's
okay though i'm with the bros surrounded
by the sulphur clouds so brace yourself
cause it's about to get loud
too much volcano no volcano
can't wait for you to take this episode
down and claim on the entire yeah
yes i will take
all the revenue do you use my song and
you defamed me
but there you go it's that easy to get
on my team's hit ladies and gentlemen
yeah apparently
apparently if you have influence online
just beg your
your underlings to go and uh buy it
pretty much pretty much
putting ascii in a song and it's
guaranteed to get on itunes yeah
how was the uh the overall journey of uh
journey cross man which was your
your is it an annual youtube series at
this point i don't know i guess so
it was right i guess it's annual yeah
did you enjoy it yeah it was really good
i wasn't there for the whole time i did
enjoy it but like you know because i'm
always running around filming and
producing
it takes a lot of stress because you've
got to think every day how's this going
to work
i nearly died on a horse yeah and in a
plane
in those videos when you say like oh
it's one day is it actually one day
for the most part yeah for the most part
it was because it's like i feel like
there's way too much stuff like what
what's
extremely hectic what time are you
waking up like 6am
some days some days yeah oh my god and
we're filming until maybe like
ten or eleven it's relentless it's a
really crazy way what's like the crew
behind that
so it's jerry myself natsuki and then we
had uh
a guy called norm take a lens and my
friend ian he's a producer
right and so it kind of works it's a
pretty small team um
quite small and that's very small i mean
we we have we had like that kind of
teams for trash day specials and even we
are
stretched to the absolute limit with
what we can do and just see i mean some
stuff you're
it's all honestly like thanks to just
like chris's insane like organizational
skills like he just has everything being
like oh yeah we don't have that
at next time we're gonna go here until
here and then doing this after this and
then all the weather's [ __ ] maybe we
should put this in front of this and me
and that's just kind of chilling in the
back like yeah all right yeah chris
somehow doubting he's too concerned with
the uh scheduling oh he loved it it's
his holiday
yeah he doesn't have to do anything
right yeah he's like riding [ __ ]
horses
he's going on a volcano dancing he's
like he literally has so
so in one of the episodes you went to a
cave or something
um didn't go in the cake yeah i know
i would have gone in the cave i would
have got it bollocks take me there we'll
go in the cage
such a humiliating day day three journey
across japan we went in the smallest
tory gate
in japan yeah about 30 centimeters
in width and height like the red shrine
thing you see
yeah this one was made of concrete and
it's on it's like concreted into the
ground
and i got stuck and i was like i'm gonna
become a fixture here if i can't get out
of it because you can't just like lift
the tires
the [ __ ] thing and i was really
scared it was like a moment where i'm
like
i'm [ __ ] like we literally had to grab
two adults like
pull him out yeah it's obvious
because you won that funny bit in the
video
it's supposed to bring you good luck but
yeah like joey
what's the good luck there but joey
literally pulled me through it's like a
beached whale being like oh my
[ __ ] it's horrible and then we went in
the cave
and i couldn't go in because of an
insect that looked like something out of
alien like a face hugger
it's your series you've got to go in
there that's what i told him on the day
and he was like you don't suffer for
your content right that's that's exactly
what people get stuck in that shrine
you can go in a cave and then there was
the horse riding
i did a i rode a horse the first time
joey got like the prize winning horse
and actually his horse was about to die
and i got and i got like the six year
old horse it was brand new the head
trained and they didn't tell me
and i was the only one that hadn't
ridden a [ __ ] horse and i got on it
and it looked it turned around and
looked at me in the eye
and it like turned where i was like i'm
[ __ ] i
knew that i was terrified yeah yeah yeah
didn't enjoy it you could feel the
energy
i turned around looked to me like i was
i was saying to krista i was like
you could tell that chris did not enjoy
it because in the video it's like
now we're riding horses and like
literally one minute later it's like and
now we're done
it's like over it's like i'm not
including any of this in the video and
that that wasn't even like
caught up for entertainment purposes it
was literally that quick was it
yeah he was he was probably on the horse
for max like three minutes
yeah it was wait how long did you ride
for it was ten minutes he rose right in
about an hour
you had a [ __ ] smoke break on the
hall [ __ ] ride
i know so it went it started going
mental and i was like i need to get off
this
and like the guy's coming over and he's
like what do you want to do get me off
this [ __ ] horse
and i'd like to throw my camera off i
sort of dived off it
it was this far from its foot and i
thought it just kicks me in the face
it's game over i'll be honest
and i thought it might because it was
like going all like this
and like the guy got on it and he could
control it either for a bit just whisper
to it
chill the [ __ ] out no you've got a sir
dominance
it can smell your fear right you can
smell your face and smell your skin yeah
do you know who i am i'm chris broad
[Laughter]
this is the best thing we've ever done
yeah it was very a lot of fun it was
very relaxing until i started to get
allergic reaction to the horse
did you actually yeah yeah you should be
allergic to horses i didn't know that
yeah
i allergic to anything i didn't know i
was allergic to horses until i got off
and i was in the car and i was like oh
my my
every orifice in my body is leaking
right now i'm like this is this is not
good and then i realized i'm probably
allergic to the whole [ __ ]
hopefully it covers on those chairs